y'all seen episode 1 of season 5 of
course yes I'm a man that loves a
bromance I've made a few movies where
dudes are in love with each other and
stuff so naturally naturally the Skiles
relationship is very close to my heart
that being said as you call the end of
the episode it's not just those two
could everybody going into the library
writing their initials on the shelf with
the yearbooks and stuff which right away
appealed to me on the sentimentality
level of like oh I'm 45 I think I
remember going to high school and stuff
like that but I loved it it's a
beautiful scene like there we are in the
Beacon Hill High School and watching all
the friends together and that's great
and then they took it one level up and
that's what this show always does and
does so exceptionally well and why I
will tune and watch a show my y'all are
here today to see the people behind it
they gave us something even better all
of a sudden we see Scott take out the
marker and he writes Alice's initials
and I started bawling as I was watching
the scene I start crying now I was
watching on my laptop and wife is
sitting over at her desk she's watching
totally different programs she sees me
crying and she's like what's the matter
and I was like he just wrote Alice's
vision and my wife looked at me like I
can't believe I sleep with you but
ladies and gentleman there's a reason
we're gathering here today man I like
you loved Teen Wolf put it together 40
Wars
[Applause]
we're gonna be lucky enough to sit here
today I talked to the people behind it
the people that make it happen man I'm
gonna bring them out give it up for each
one as they come out as if they're you
know Jesus coming into Nazareth or
something like that without this guy
ladies and gentlemen you got no show man
he created it he grunts it he's the man
give it up for Jeff David
you know it's it's it's a boy's world
and team Wolf's not so much as girls as
well man lots of ladies on this show
ladies who cook bass here's one of a man
give it up for Shelley Hennig I have
watched this kid become such a great
actor over the last five seasons I stole
him and I put him into a movie called
the oka hosers ma'am he is the team
won't give it up
[Applause]
we didn't break anything this time did
you know broken thumb no broken toes
this time I don't think so they
approached my blood I don't know how you
follow an entrance like that but there's
one guys going to be able to do it man
whose half Skiles give it up for fire
[Applause]
I'm happy Tuesday
this next person has actually been in my
house man she's really cool man give it
up
[Applause]
all mode there two more people man
welcome to the stage ladies and
gentlemen the only Mary that matters
Dylan Sprayberry
[Music]
and last but not least the man with the
alliterative name which fits right here
at comic-con give it up for calling
question okay
we're gonna get into it I'm gonna do a
few minutes of questions of these guys
but your questions matter far more so
we'll do a few and then we're gonna turn
it right over to you guys but I want to
start with that scene I was talking
about Jeff I loved it I was like I want
to interrupt I got a present for you
yeah yeah we have got band together as a
cast and crew and gotten you your own
Beacon Hill's
[Applause]
the love goes both ways here in this you
have no idea what this needs to be bad
I'm gonna wear this when I sleep with
that wife of mine okay so I just talked
about before I get out here the opening
of this season that that moment in the
library as a writer I was jealous
because I was like that had to come
nobody could just create that he had to
take it from his real life is that a
tradition that you stole from your own
life or what no actually we made it up
in the writers room we have a few good
ideas sometimes send it back it was
actually it was inspired by the actress
who played Allison or James crystal Reed
and it was was a way for us to pay
tribute to one of the actors who had
been on the show and I mean in TV these
days the dead pile up there are so many
shows my my favorite show on TV right
now Game of Thrones where everybody so
it's nice to be able to pay tribute to a
great great actor and a character that I
created a long time ago it feels like
now and to be able to say I miss her how
many that haven't this is season five
did you ever think you'd be doing five
seasons I it's fine we're getting into
fine B now and it's 70 episodes and I
gotta say back in Atlanta when we were
shooting that pilot Tyler did you ever
think we would we would get to 70
episodes oh my god I don't know my 70 I
I just I knew the show was great and I
always wanted to get I never had any
expectations of anything but I wanted to
go forever do you want to do a few more
yes I would love to I think I think MTV
does too because they just ordered a
sixth season
go team with everybody coming back to
doing what your coming back to Dylan
yeah that's fantastic so when do you
guys when did they tell you that sort of
thing
they they tell you usually right before
this sort of thing and I called my
lawyer and I'm like did they give me all
the money I wanted and I'm like no and
let's do it anyway you we were talking
once about like the show is very highly
rated and on MTV but it also has this
ghost audience that just finds it
illegally online or something like that
yes you all that lady right there you
keep them out that Natalie and Karen
over there they steal the show attacked
by them with the numbers like tell them
how many week oh well I should Paul 2014
we did a hundred and eighteen million
streams which is incredible and then our
aggregate number is upwards of 8 million
per episode so it's a very you
Millennials and and people under 25 to
watch the show in very different ways
these days and so as long as you guys
keep watching it they'll probably keep
making it thank you guys
we talk to everybody but I want to talk
to Tyler and Dylan real quick because
the heart of the show is the bromance
between you guys that's what I love
about the show it's about two dudes who
are loved we'll just never mate but
that's what you think man in other words
he's never been our fan of season six
you guys you're chemistry is very
natural I remember we were making or
maybe do Gosar's I was like you guys
really hang out again we're actually
like friends you guys are became friends
did you know each other priority yeah
you'd think so I was actually just
phoning up just working with someone and
then they're asking me about Tyler and I
told them this whole story I like talk
forever about Tyler what everyone asks
me about him I like talk for an hour
about how we met at the audition and
then we just clicked instantly talked
about bands there's just a moment we
were just like yeah it was the same
person and even even if we hadn't gotten
those parts we had exchanged numbers
that day and we were gonna hang out and
then we both call each other later we
were like did you get it
I remember you said that's what you
called me like yo homie so I just heard
I got it I was like I got it too it was
the coolest I couldn't even tell ya like
it was the I just I saw all this
happening like a flash of just like our
lives to play it out it was the happiest
yeah it's actually amazing because it
honestly is it's like it's really rare a
thing to actually have a genuine
relationship you know I mean it's there
can be so many versions of it you can be
tolerant of one another you can hate
each other you can like like them but
like you know they're not your person
you know what I mean and we're just like
brothers and I just think that's insane
good audience yes it's actually amazing
cuz you I've heard about TV shows well
you just got the room get moist it
cool as a as a fan of TV myself I've had
I've had favourite shows where I hear
behind-the-scenes stuff where they like
hate each other they can't stand to be
in Spears together anymore but these
guys love each other I remember kind of
you remember I sent you an email like
the first week saying you should hang
out together yes yes just like okay so
you guys are gonna you guys are great
friends you've been friends forever your
characters I want you guys to you know
get some chemistry and start hanging out
with each other and I texted I'm like
we've already been doing that where I'm
spending night at his house tonight we
have sleepovers we sleep over they fall
asleep playing Halo
aside personal all in order to pizza to
her car that is true only the best time
to respond huh I don't like the commute
home so I parking lot and it's around
the time that Caitlyn Jenner was doing
that big interview don't think I'm gonna
watch that video legally and order pizza
and I just told them where which parking
lot I was in and Domino's so they'll
just come to a car they're that
desperate we'll deliver to your car at
the back of rolls
okay great what's phone number like it's
been done it's been done in Los Angeles
Jeff you got to pay these kids more man
I don't write the check
Bob who's the new kid who's the newest
howdy Christian now let me ask you this
and put you on the spot because clearly
there's tons of chemistry with people
have been together a lot as a family is
it weird to jump into a show where
you're like I'm the new guy and they're
like we've known each other we've all
seen each other naked you know that kind
of thing is it weird being it's like the
first day it's cool for you I would
imagine them yeah no it totally is I
actually just showed up to the set naked
so we saw oh no it was there's always
trepidation and fear like coming into
like a set that's been established and
especially show it's been together for
five seasons you know but thankfully
there's there's something special here
with with Teen Wolf and I kind of just
jumped right in and
you know everything just kind of you
know just happened and I felt like I
joined a family and I'm so grateful for
that so so likewise dude you have been
you just you got it what do you fit in
so damn well and we love you we love we
love you so much man thank you so much
let's keep the love going Dylan yeah
you're the only team in Teen Wolf is
that true yeah yeah each n and if I I
detected a little bit of throwing shade
early this season do you have an eye on
the elf or what yeah you know it's I'm
glad you asked me that question I'm
sorry did I have a STONER moment and ask
you the question that I meant to ask no
or did you jump in because it's to
Dylan's that is weird and confusing but
I was talking to the the sweeter the
berry the sweeter the juice go ms grant
right right so yeah so you know I'm 16
and just turned 17 maybe you should go
back to have until an answer for you
yeah it's really better no yeah there's
definitely there will be some conflict
of Scott and I obviously I can't stay
too much because Jeff's right there I
don't want to get in trouble he was
gonna be bugging you from the side he
knows that I'm
I'm really bad is when things are good
but we will see some part of that now
it's out of the way that's good shake it
off and we move on shall you come from
other shows not just this show how does
it compare when you come from another
world and then jump into this world
other ones in films elsewhere the cast
is amazing but I've been very lucky I
feel like I've worked with some amazing
actors but this definitely feels like a
family forever and not to sound really
cheesy but you guys I mean I was new
once I would have not been on the show
since season 1 but it feels like I've
been with you guys for a while and
that's because they've accepted me since
I went to set and it's been amazing
that's all Dillon and Tyler two doing in
Tyler said that it set the tone well
you're off ordering pizzas and parking
lots or not nobody want that tone set no
more questions for me everybody let me
ask you this man to the ladies
particularly the seems like the level of
VAS chicory with the girl characters and
particularly as jealous then
[Applause]
that satisfy your like if somebody
handed me a script they're like you're
even more actually I'd be like oh man I
like sitting down do you dig that part
of the job is that like oh it's better
than just watching people fight I like
fighting myself I start there and then
go there I mean look I can be lazy but I
mean if you're working you're working
right so you might as well be active so
for me I love it because I don't get
bored
there's always something to rehearse or
choreograph and I was a dancer so it was
hauling so we really appreciate the the
physical side of it and it just makes
sense to me that girls are kick-ass like
and I forget that sometimes it's to me
that's just normal but I also grew up
with two older brothers who beat the
[ __ ] out of me so I learned to
self-defense at a very young age so it
just makes sense that females are strong
and in fight you shouldn't be going
around physically fighting them I
advocate the kicking of ass
ah yeah so it makes sense to me and I
love it it's my favorite thing is it a
hard to memorize what's harder
memorizing dialogue or memorizing fight
choreography you're taking too long
column dancers it was actually quite fun
and you had to remind yourself to like
make sure it actually looks like the
punch and so forth and instead of a move
right right and and and I would like
Shelley I was the older sister of a
younger brother and I think it was home
improvement than his little brother
attacked and I then incorporated that
into my family and made him pay me money
and so I actually like I think provoked
a lot of advice first it's defending
myself and there's a reason why you're
alone and parking lots eating these two
ladies I'm putting it together now she
found out she was a a werewolf show
season two and so it was just nice of
her to join the rest of the new pond
into the pack and meet the stunt
coordinators I've joked in the past and
it was awesome
I mean I it's kind of like when you are
at school and you have that Restless
like I want to go to recess PE thing and
just like get aggression out you get to
put on the different hats where you're
not having to memorize math problems so
I'll I appreciate the retest of acting
which is does their why I could sit here
and ask questions all day but they want
to open it up to them basis they came
here to ask questions so let's turn on
some lights and go to some mics and hear
from the crowd thank you for your
questions
yes
[Applause]
sign our we start here in the middle of
that it boy we know this kid hey that's
Tyler right yes how's it going I'm good
how's that award oh yeah I still have it
at home and so a by the way that you
guys have two best wife I ever like I
said like home last year teams Oh mr.
Haeckel bear we are home here can't even
tell you how much we missed cycle bit
yeah so that my question is for for all
of you guys every single actors and
actresses how would you advise every
single fans to who wants to become an
actor and actresses about you guys start
will start good let me grab the mic go
Dylan you start I was just suggesting um
you know what I mean I I think at the
core of what we do at the end of the day
we I think everyone can agree up here
that we all love to do what we do love
sets we love the process of filmmaking
we love our role that we play in it and
that all starts somewhere that starts
when you're young and you're a kid and
you love making videos or vines or now I
mean or whatever the hell it is but you
do it because you love it you love
movies and that's what you love to do so
I always just try to encourage to just
always see that first I guess and to
never let go of that never get caught up
and trying to make it or trying to you
know because the business is so fickle
it's so random
that really all that matters is just
like doing it and the fact that you're
passionate about that and so you can do
it every day just yourself with friends
with like I mean it's one you know all
your guys has phones now anyway you can
make a video I mean you can cut and do
anything you want making Blake make
little movies do a little you know
shorts with your friends I mean that's
what I always
then to further that point the
technology like Final Cut Pro and you
know people that make music I think it's
about Ableton I mean you've got the
professional technology that you guys
have access to now and so you see so
many actors making their own material
because now they're just like you guys
they have access to make their own
material and a easier route than maybe
10 years ago or even five years ago so
yeah damn just like just stay passionate
like till said love what you do like at
the end of the day we all really really
love what we do whether it's I mean I
also love just being on set - and and
staying humble and and doing this kind
of stuff I don't know I don't know just
stay humble that's my biggest and make
your own material yeah and remember I
know you didn't ask me but this advice
Johnson knows he hires everybody so I
can give it I can give the perspective
of the producer behind the behind the
table
remember that Fame is a byproduct Fame
is not the not what you're after treated
like a craft and if you're a craftsman
be treated like an art for the craft
[Applause]
we also have we have this view of you
and this close-up of you two right here
so we're staring it yeah people have
helped me get through some really rough
spots in my life and I just wanted to
thank you guys for that it's always
remind me to be my own anchor and just
okay that's amazing
I wanted to know my favorite story arc
was nogitsune Stiles which you did
amazing by the way that was awesome
thank you and my question was what your
favorite art was throughout to you all
to all of us I think your mic went out
so I'll speak for you all of us what our
favorite team the park has been I got an
answer it was a girl that shipped these
individual pictures of all the Teen Wolf
characters it's probably Jeff stands and
maybe I don't know and and they shipped
them to the office and it was these like
black and white I don't even know how to
explain it it was like shadowing and
this is your favorite storyline is it
it's the favorite if you're finished did
you meet you soon I don't know we're
just telling me you guys can bail that
you got fan art
[Music]
we're gonna shut Holland's mic off and
continue first first of all what you
said in the beginning about how team of
us helps you and saved you and and
continue to help you through things I
love that that's all I ever want to hear
and and we've gotten a lot of that so
thank you for sharing I know it's hard
sharing that so thank you for doing it
of all these people answer your question
my favorite art I think was void Stiles
I love void Stiles and I thought you did
a really good job man yeah yeah okay we
got it we got to let Holland answer that
now what's your favorite art
against this ban part which I'm very
well aware of hearing from let me tell
you how smart Colin is actually because
she she was still doing college courses
during the second season and I said
Holland you can stop you're going you're
really good act she obviously did major
all right favorite storyline new kids
named Floyd Stiles
really I love the actor that came in he
wanted to UM I think he had like another
obligation they tried can we work out
scheduling anyone's ever just like no
dude you did the best you don't even see
my face like yeah that's how good you
are we don't even see this guy's face
thanks Aaron and he's impeccable
it was actually the character was
supposed to be the character that he'll
get Sanae what we what we created with
the bandages and the steel teeth was
only supposed to be in one or two
episodes and Aaron Henry the actor it
was so good we kept bringing him back
their chemistry yeah they would
right Sprayberry you gotta say something
sorry
I really I really liked Scott last
season Scott for I really liked your arc
at the end of like in the finale you
know when you trying to scout the wizard
Cody Cody Christian has not seen the
first two seasons I know but with that
said he has watched a whole other 36
episodes of the show that is not the
first two seasons so I think that's
commendable
yeah right that's amazing actually what
happened was when I got on the show I
binge watched season 3 and season four
three days before we started filming so
I watched the most ridiculous amount of
Teen Wolf in one sitting
anything filming ever since yeah it was
insane but for me I'm gonna go with
everyone else I think Dylan O'Brien was
absolutely incredible
[Applause]
ya know gift today was definitely my
favorite
Scott's character right now season five
yeah he's definitely going to some
places we haven't seen you got go to
before and I'm excited for everyone to
see that amen
really really excited for you guys to
see the upcoming episodes I think we put
all into this it's it's kind of actually
I'll say I'll give my props to them this
amazing task that's it's kind of an
extraordinary to be doing 70 episodes
and to see them still getting a-plus
performances all the time and getting
better and better
[Applause]
I was wondering where the safir's like
he cannot protect his back as well as he
used to in the seasons before as we see
the more human side of him in this
season or maybe there's someone in his
back who you feel can protect them
better so for example when Maria got up
before him from the kanima venom I felt
like maybe she's getting stronger mm-hmm
I mean that's that's huge
do you want to take this that's I'm glad
that you brought that up because that's
that's oh my god what did you say
it's gone it's gone Scott Scott feels
like he can't handle this one pack yes
that's a point that's like that's like
that's nice
that's much did it get awkward that's
one of the things that we're dealing
with this season is the fact that
Scott's pack is falling apart around him
and he normally knows what he's doing
and has a plan of action for everything
and things are really falling apart
around him and he can't figure out what
it is or why so I think he is dealing
with the idea that maybe somebody can
can handle the pack or be a better alpha
than he can which is uh interesting
because Scott's never really dealt with
that idea before he's the first season
he was in a really vulnerable state
because he was this outcast and also and
he was a werewolf and it just flipped
his whole world upside down and like he
just just hated life and now and he
learned to deal with it and became this
leader and now he's kind of lost and so
it's something we got to really dealt
with before so it's um it's it's I think
my favorite storyline
I'll give it t--'s to for for the rest
of the upcoming season that something
happens in Episode five at the beginning
of the episode that causes a rift
between Scott and Stiles and threatens
their relationship
and it's it's something that Theo uses
so you'll see you'll see these two on
possibly headed towards a breakup thank
you hi my name is star my question is if
you could switch roles with any of the
characters on the show
just watch it with Scott I always say
Derek I think I think Derek is such a
dark brooding person with such depth to
him I would love to play plus he doesn't
shave and I I would like to grow out my
beard that was answered in such a way
that you've been thinking about it for a
while
like on set go I'm like I could out do
it later like one day Peter you'll get
yours oh let me get back I will father
myself okay I'm on my game today Ken
what ears my brain my mouth I'm on that
note um coach I I think he's amazing
[Applause]
Jeff saw him performing stand-up and I
love that he transferred that we missed
Arnie yeah he coaches mind everything
the drama and that's what I love that it
comes across this comedy I would be
sheriff stilinski I always say that that
would be so much fun
because I love bling didn't looking such
a great actor and I would love to try to
to do what he does with that character I
don't know he's just he's there's
something about his character that I
don't think anyone else could do and I
would like to try to do that yeah we got
that the first time
yeah I said that a few times I'm Cody I
think for me this is hard because you
know Tyler executes the role so
perfectly but I would love to try to
play Scott for a day and see what it
feels like to be the Alpha Team wolf you
you would kill it homie you would
absolutely kill it I would love to see
that too
[Applause]
they're so adorably supportive of one
another it's really sweet hi how are you
hi Alyssa I was just wondering if you
guys feel any sort of like
responsibility to inspire young girls
and like show them that women can be
smart and strong that's a great question
absolutely I mean I think we've been
given such a great platform to do that
and I think Jeff writes the best female
characters because they are strong and
smart and let's be honest a lot of
female characters on television are not
unless I'm they all aren't but I think
Jeff really writes strong female
characters and that's kind of rare
especially for this age category too so
yeah and I to be honest it was Comic Con
last year that it really hit me because
I just I just do it right I I love what
I do and I don't I try not to think too
much and it was actually whoever was
here in this room last year they
responded off of something that I said
about you know playing strong kick-ass
female character and I was like whoa I
didn't realize how far that has touched
people so you guys have shown me that
it's going a long way and it feels
really good and I'm just happy that Jeff
has allowed us to do that
yeah in school I learned well in college
I actually learned I was a science major
but I switch to women's studies and
funnily enough when I was at an
all-girls school for 13 years from five
till 16 so it wasn't until I was 16
sitting in the class with boy I also
know summer camp too so that might
answer a few questions and I I never
really realized boys changed the dynamic
that how girls act sometimes can be
changed around boys and on top of that I
in women's studies I learned as far as
women in their team it go one in four
women that was it and I thought it
didn't even seem like that to me it was
almost more like Shelia but not really
realizing there were the dichotomy of
75% more men on TV than women and then
out of that percentage or something like
90 percent that played secondary
characters again didn't even really
think about it didn't realize it until
you look at the heart facts and it
wasn't until I was on Jeff's show that
people come up to you and it's easier
either an aesthetic connection or it's a
character connection and you don't
really realize you're a role model until
you're talking to the little girl in
front of you and I am obviously not a
mother I don't have children but it's
funny you feel like this big sister
connection to these two you guys that
come up to to us and and talk to us
about your problems or something that
you're insecure about or something that
you're excited about your future about
you trying to get advice from us who are
you know put some of you that are old
well older than you it's been a nice
connection to all of those different
levels and I look back on my life when I
talk to you guys and I think about my
background and hopefully with art your
generation
we different and those percentages will
not stay the same and so as far as it's
really you guys it's an organic thing I
think it's just coming up through your
life it's almost like a big sister thing
of looking back on my life that's a
really long-winded answer I can I just
wanna add that when we shot Holland's
opener 501 and we saw her we were
sitting behind a monitor saying [ __ ]
she's like Black Widow
she's almost it was exciting to see and
I think there should be a black widow
movie personally but but uh I love
seeing ass-kicking girls on screen I
mean Kyra Arden who couldn't be here
she's in Singapore doing a concert and
miss her couldn't make it again but her
with the sword in the last episode and
the Fox spirit surrounding her it's
awesome and it's nice to hear that
people respond so so amazingly well to
it so it'll be more an ass-kicking to
come yeah I'm gonna tag up on that
though and just ask like your 40 year
old man writing for high school girls
weird it yeah and he's doing Gracie do
you have one in a box somewhere no like
tell me answer
how you do that where do you draw it
from it's funny because whenever I try
to remember my own high school
experience they've been repressed so far
in my brain it's hard to dig out but I I
just try to write the truth really I'm a
40 year old game man so not that far
from a teenage girl is mainly for Jeff
and I know a lot of the fans will be
asking you this question as well what's
the next time
sorry you're the one - next time we will
see Derek
[Applause]
a good question let's get let's Paul I
could answer that actually should I call
hoechlin would that be great I'd call
him right now and say when the hell are
you getting your ass back to Teen Wolf
are you all calling him because then
it's not gonna work I will tell you this
it's up to him
so tweeting tweet isn't telling get your
ass back to Teen Wolf yeah so again we
have a lot of power as a 12 year old you
acted your like a preteen
all right next up stem sighs honey we
got business to get to how are you wait
before I remember you
[Music]
doing no don't do not make her cry again
[Music]
[Applause]
directed to take the heat off you a
little bit on this of these questions
yeah all the behind the scenes to have a
lot a lot of these characters have to do
with contracts yeah so just saying Jack
would love to have everyone on the show
always it's very true for once it's
actually not the showrunner killing the
actor off
I mean reality is it's a business and
people are looking at it up you know
pathways but hopefully people you guys
oh my god this is crazy
[Applause]
it's uh how do I swim I say we're told
me we are on the Teen Wolf panel at
comic-con right now when you run smooth
and you're fed through the microphone
say something to the fans
[Applause]
[Applause]
do you miss you do you everyone wants to
know do you miss Derek do you miss Derek
everyone wants to know right now it's
like 4:00 in the morning all right mommy
I think everyone just everyone just
wanted to hear that
[Music]
[Applause]
tell them to text us
[Music]
right
[Applause]
huzi you made a strong arm is gonna be
pissed if he comes back in you kidding
takes the job you get 10% yeah how you
doing what do you want to know I've been
here since 12 but it's every second has
been worth it holy [ __ ] I just wanted to
ask
like if Styles were to become any
supernatural creature character creature
what would he want to be what are my
options just like anything in the world
or anything that's been on the show
anything okay what was it yeah Dylan
what it was he said he said in season
two when Matt asked you vomit will
snowman it's more of a seasonal oh yeah
oh yeah vomiting oh man I want to be the
abominable Mets fan
[Music]
literally literally leave I'm not
kidding we leave why are you here
why are you here do you like the show
do you like T inching ever closer come
to the Phantom Awards tonight you'll see
my pants go on you'll see me with no
pants on yeah oh no I just want to ask
one question while we have Kevin here
what is it yoga hoser
that's his Kevin's new movie the Tyler
Posey is starring yeah it's it's a movie
about two girls that work in a
convenience store and Tyler plays one of
the boys that they're kind of in love
with and my daughter your daughter
oldest man so I trusted him with my dog
thanks baby
let's go to them though this person
wants to know something hi nice sweater
repping the Beacon Hill's the cross I
contribute nothing but thank you
and we were wondering this is a question
kind of directed toward Dylan and Tyler
Dylan O'Brien then you just squashed the
berry over there man inner circle to
trust do coming into beacon hills
than it was for them to trust Keira and
Malia when they were new characters
because they're cute because worth a
minute or females boobies towards the
girl that's what I was trying to get
basic natural sixteen-year-old instinct
you know the girls you'll be like
alright they're pretty I don't like
these guys are gonna impede on my pretty
girls honest of an answer I guess yeah
I'm gonna give ya it's over this is over
the answer to this question has
concluded his boys get very territorial
over their girls when they're young
right yeah I don't know I always I've
always thought of it too as I was a
little I was a little suspicious of here
- when she first came along I think
Stiles is pretty suspicious of everyone
yeah he's just super super loyal and
protective and you know feisty little
mama bear style look we gotta move on no
we're gonna watch you tangle with this
for a while
oh here we go we have time for one more
question they get long make it long
stretch it out my name is Brenna and my
question is for everyone being the
senior year well except for lead
character but he can say something we
love you don't worry for your characters
what would your senior quote yeah
seriously I don't know probably
something that would suck up to Scott
best please let me in your back my the
better villain yes you go what's your
senior token it would be
give me a scream Cori what give me a
scream chord give me a scream Cori that
would be a robot I'm gonna have to take
a tip out of Jeff's book and stay not
all monsters - monsters things pretty
indicative to Lydia's boyfriend history
and choice of frettin sometimes Lydia
and season one herself
so not all monsters - monsters thanks
[Music]
get your hands off my Jeep
[Applause]
you guys are gonna cry with this one the
pack is my anchor gosh [ __ ] is that your
quote I can't follow just writing sorry
uh I'll say my one of my favorite quotes
from the show is be your own anchor I
would put that in my senior yearbook if
I could go back he said no I would I
would go back to if I could go back to
my senior year and choose a different
quote I would say be your own anchor
[Applause]
you